le centre ville se meurt en silence et
ses commerçants de la rue antoine siger
n'en peuvent plus de voir leur voisin
faire faillite et fermer boutique
ce matin leur blocage mise en place à 8
heures semblent bien dérisoires quelques
palettes pour attirer l'attention
les seuls à réagir ce matin seront les
agents de police municipale
mais la désertion des clients en période
de grève demeure
ces professionnels avancent une chute du
chiffre d'affaires de 70 % à quelques
jours de noël la moyenne de la journée
se situe entre 20 et 40 euros par jour
alors que là on est bien achalandés
comme les moins cher que partout et
qu'on ne peut pas arriver avant à cause
de toutes ces difficultés là que nous
subissons grève des bus à répétition un
marché fermé des clients qui ne viennent
plus des commerces laissé à l'abandon
des gens qui sont dans le déficit des
familles qui sont qui sont au bord de la
crise de nerfs
j'ai décidé de prendre l'initiative de
faire quelque chose de boucher la route
pour se faire écouter ce qui révolte le
plus c'est chefs d'entreprise et le
silence assourdissant des élus de tous
bords comme de l'état alors que sont
rapidement sommés de libérer la rue le
transport public peut rester paralysé
sans que personne ne semble s'en
émouvoir de peugeot ont la bave des
décors et des bus jusqu'à maintenant
aucun élu politiquement
même à bouger et ça reste comme ça donc
vous pourrez la loi dans ce cas il n'ya
pas de loi donc on est livrés à
eux-mêmes à l'abandon et sans réelles
perspectives d'avenir
ses façades envahi par la végétation en
disent long qui voudra un jour venir y
investir à nouveau